Chân đường đến cây ta chưởng thầy.
Sợ tình lấy tông ốn nền tạng,
ở dưới dụng sẽ được chuyền thông,
với thông điểm mạnh mẽ rằng
việc nền cấp này không chỉ,
một nền cấp để ký phật.
Mà đó là sự khám kết của sợ tôn nền đối xế phát triển lâu dài
và bước chắc của nền thẻ thao,
gần nền xa bước.
Sợ bước của lệnh sẽ không chỉ nền một lưỡng dục,
mà là bước đầu dụng một quốc chuyện đổi số trong cái bước kẻ thao,
chúng tôi tin đường dàng dàng đến nền tạng mạnh mẽ hơn,
với bệnh nền trọng tài và chủ dài sẽ có những
plân thiệt vui ổ,
đánh cùng nhau đưa không chào thể thao lên bước phát triển mới.
Thêm mặt người làm mình thao này.
Rất là tặng nền,
mạnh hơn nền cấp sợ tăng,
ở phía lưỡi tác,
và nhạc này chờ,
đã hấu chộ đồng hành nguyễn thảo Việt Nam trong nhiều đúng qua.
Và chúc chó,
là sợ bắt phần nịch,
sẽ này có phát triển.
Để sống chình gấp bệnh của vừa đuí chính xác,
thì điều hành gái đấu,
và các chuyên nghiệm,
và chúng tôi cũng sợ về đó,
cũng có phối ổ phí,
và nhạc nước để mà chúng ta này cả
đưa để thả Việt Nam,
không nhập hát triển cho khu vực và xin đi rối.
Hôm nay sau gần bà năm 2020,
và gần hai đâm đi vào,
cũng giúp sau điều hành gái đảo,
để xong phóc tôn lấy cho tổ chức quảy,
lấy hành trình chuyển mình,
để chia n tất cả những hành lối tác.
Đả á làm việc cùng phóc tôn lấy,
và sẽ mọi gà một chặt đường mới,
chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau phát triển.
Cùng nhau có những bất liên dột phá để phát triển phóng chào,
phát triển phóng chào,
tẹn thào của tẹn đồng,
nhau chung,
xin chất sòng cảm ơn,
các chuyên chi yu,
giữ lối tác và xe mặt,
đã đến tập dưới trình bệ lạc.